the european green deal is our blueprint
for europe to become the first climate
neutral continent
by 2050. it strives for systemic change
and
modernization across our economy our
societies
and industry of course energy transition
is at its heart and this is why i warmly
welcome
the opportunity to join forces with
breakthrough energy
i am excited to announce a new
partnership between breakthrough energy
and the european commission i've created
breakthrough energy catalyst
a first of its kind innovative finance
vehicle
designed to rapidly commercialize
critical climate smart
technologies to succeed in preventing
the climate crisis the world will need
a new approach to building global
industries
this is the greatest opportunity for
innovation
the world has ever seen the catalyst
program is targeting the technologies we
need
for europe to become carbon neutral we
want to deploy
invest eu with the european investment
bank
and i hope national financial partners
and on top invest eu allows member
states
to mobilize funds for example from
eu programs like next generation eu
in europe we're lucky to have a wealth
of scientists and innovators leading the
way to decarbonization
we just need to help them to bring
their ideas to the market
europe will be a strong partner because
of its early and consistent commitment
to climate
we have to act bold and fast and
together
we can achieve our green goals to the
benefit
of people and businesses